salesforce says the nine to five work
the work
day is dead they will provide three ways
to for employees to work including
working from home salesforce on tuesday
now said its employees would have the
option to work from home
remotely full-time even even when it's
safe to return to the office the new
guidelines which sell forces calling the
work from anywhere offers employs three
options
uh flex fully remote office-based sales
forces the decision to offer new ways of
working was based on employees well
wellness survey the company had been
sending around since the onset of the
pandemic okay so guess what
they sent a what a survey something more
cuban ought to do
something mark cuban ought to do for
employees who work within the flex
option they'll report to the office
between one or three days each week for
tasks that are more challenging to do
over video calls such as team
collaboration customer meetings and
presentations salesforce said it's most
of its employees
worldwide would have a flex schedule an
immersive work schedule workspace is no
longer
limited to a desk in our towers the
nine-to-five work that is dead the
employee experience is about here's the
big part pay attention here though
pink punk tables and snacks that's a
shot straight at
you you're number one it is a shot at vt
brent heider the president of the chief
police uh people office of salesforce
said that salesforce okay so what do you
think about this what do you think about
the direction sales force is going do
you agree do you disagree with them well
this guy mark benioff has clearly proven
himself to be a leader
uh in the business community yeah i got
a lot of respect for this guy
salesforce uh you know they they they
start trends they don't just kind of
follow them they've come out and said
wfa is a lifestyle now baby wfa work
from anywhere
and you have three options who's in
favor of three options we're in favor of
three options around here what do we got
what do we got you got this flex
schedule
we come in the office a couple days of
the week you work from home a couple
days a week
do what you got to get done you got the
fully remote
we never even see your ass you're just
you're working remote
you want to get a big time job this guy
actually lives in uh
indiana uh typically we couldn't get
this guy in here but or a gal
we're gonna have him work a remote from
indiana let's bring in some talent
let's pay them what we got to pay them
they're working fully remote and then
there's obviously office base
but the beauty right now is we got
options
you got options options that didn't
exist per se
before this pandemic so basically mark
benioff ceo of salesforce is saying
listen
the nine to five is dead i think we can
agree right here nine to five
is a very old school mentality when it
comes to work
show up you know sit sit at your desk at
nine o'clock
take your lunch at noon be done by 12
30. you know
after that you gotta you know the people
what do we what's the joke that you make
the 459 crowd what's the joke that you
make for them
459 they are they are standing up and
stretching they are out the door we got
blueberries running wild here
but the the most beautiful thing that
you can do and everyone does it here
at valuetainment is you show up when you
show up
you leave when you need to leave and
your gsd you get your [ __ ] done
okay and for the nine to five crowd you
know who you're making your salary
you're making your 30 or 40 grand
whatever whatever whatever
the people get stuff done they don't
necessarily abide by nine to five you
come and you and as long as you enjoy
what you're doing
you'll work from anywhere you work
remote and i just think it's impressive
that he's giving the people the options
now and i think that's the future of
what do you think
i mean we've seen this in silicon valley
and i think to in essence i'm agreeing
with what adam's saying here
of the options um it also depends on
obviously the work that they're doing
some things you can't do
and some things you can do remotely in
the in towards the end he also mentioned
that it obviously widens their pool for
talent which is another thing but i also
think that if if the work
if this is truly the way things are
moving then
virtually how would would you as
somebody stand out
more as opposed to like in an office i
mean you're you're a ceo you're a
founder
how would somebody that's one place
where i can see an issue is like how do
you efficiently
stand out or become more of a linchpin
if you're just kind of
so here's mike here's my question for
you so maybe we ought to
forever only watch video games through
zoom
not video games uh sports sporting games
like nbas we should not go to
games anymore why why do we go to the
game why don't we just watch it from tv
what's the difference from going to yeah
then actually watching it from tv
maybe we should drop school and no
longer have to go to school and
everybody
just goes to school from home on a zoom
maybe we should do that maybe we should
do that
i don't like that wait a minute why not
what's the maybe maybe moving forward
church should only be from home you know
not
not going to a actual place a sanctuary
a church maybe we should just do it
through zoom and somebody preaches and
you just kind of you do worship from
you know from home and not go to church
and we just kind of do
maybe maybe super bowl there should be
no fans in there you know maybe
maybe all-star game there should be
nobody in there you know where lebron
says i see no reason for us to have an
in the all-star game fan's not going to
be there so maybe maybe everything we
should do we shouldn't be around each
other anymore i think that's a bad idea
maybe we should do that maybe that's the
direction to go because we don't really
need human interaction
you know we can do it through zoom i
mean talking to my dad over phone is the
same as seeing them face to face
right that's what it is what's the big
difference
i mean who cares about a hug who cares
about a handshake
who cares about how you're doing that's
not that valuable
you know who cares about sitting down
here having this kind of a conversation
we should do this from a zoom you should
stay home why are we guys here
we should do a podcast from home you
shouldn't be here right now we shouldn't
be doing it this way
why do we come over here to work people
forget
this is human beings you're talking
about how the hell do you build a
culture
working from home how do you do it how
do you build a culture why
why do you go to a concert ask somebody
who went to a michael jackson concert
what they'll tell you
they talk about it till today ask
somebody who watched michael jordan play
a game score 45 points on a sunday
that everybody else was watching on tv
and they were there ask somebody who was
at a game when reggie jackson had three
home runs in the game mr october
what did it feel like when you were in
there versus somebody that watched it on
tv
ask somebody who was there when doug
flutie threw that touchdown for boston
college
what's the difference between that and
the highlights we watch on tv
look i'm not sitting here saying certain
industries this works for
okay i have a chief information officer
guy that works with us he says pat
here's how engineers are
very good very a guy i trust he's very
uh
the way he explains things is my style i
like it a lot
and for engineers i get it
yeah they're wired in a different way
everything else
i don't know it doesn't apply 100 to
every industry this is not a black and
white across the board everybody you
can't do it that way
because you can't build a culture that
way for example
video game if you want to have a a video
game
competition can you do it from your
house sure fine
can you do a poker tournament from your
house okay fine is it different than you
watching the world series to everybody
sitting at the table
not the same when you're watching them
talking to each other all this i can't
see your eyes i can
it's a very different story
we human beings are not robots
we human beings have emotions
we in human beings have feelings we
human beings have different
senses and those senses are only being
used
when you're around what others you can
say all this stuff you want and
give me a great pitch on it that this is
the directions going everybody can work
from home forever
fine do it it could work for some
companies
can work for everybody and then the idea
of culture so
if you were to say what is the biggest
company in the world today that people
talk about culture
what's the company that's culture
culture culture culture culture google
that everybody netflix netflix oh yeah
reed hayson said i'm not a fan of this
he's not a fan of working from home
forever why not
when you think about culture does
anybody ever says the sales force
culture
no they have a great product they have a
genius run at a company
but when you think about netflix what do
people say they have a great culture
what did jobs say about culture what did
growth say about culture
what did anybody that ever built an
incredible company say about culture you
kidding me how do you build culture
through zoom
how do you do it there's nothing like
face-to-face building culture so i
i'm not sitting here saying i disagree
i'm not sitting here saying i
i think that is the direction we're
going i think some of the industries yes
but if you want to build a culture it's
going to be very very
difficult trying to do it all from home
we have some people writing on the
company
all we do is zoom we don't do trainings
anymore really yeah they're being left
behind by others who are doing
face to face they can do what they want
to do based on the guidelines or
whatever the state offers
we're just going to do zoom moving
forward we're not gonna i'm gonna go out
there and live over here and i don't
even need to be on my office
fine you know what we've noticed
happened to their business last six
months
gradual decline then the people that are
together seeing each other office all
we know what we notice with them gradual
increase
how do you measure that you know you
have certain players in the nba
that you can't measure their statistics
you can't measure draymond green
you just cannot measure him but how much
does he do for the game
a lot you can't measure a patrick
beverly
okay but how much does he do for the
game a lot you can't measure a lot of
the stuff rodman did
and it's not just rebounds he didn't
score but what did rodman do
oh my gosh none of that stuff has a
leaders bulletin
how he had carl malone dropped four
times on the same walk back
you know after you know you know which
one i'm talking about finally he got so
upset annoyed and caramel couldn't make
the shots because all he kept thinking
about is how annoying cool is
dennis rodman is yeah so the point i'm
trying to make tangibles
the intangibles you cannot discredit the
intangibles just because the intangibles
don't
show data you have to pay attention to
it
and i don't know if a lot of people are
paying attention to it this is too early
this is too early for us to jump to
conclusions saying
this is the one way to go that is the
one we still haven't seen the side
effects of it it's still going to take
us a year two years three years for
somebody have a definite philosophy
these are all testing philosophies cove
it's only been around for a year it's
not even many years i mean
of course we're in the middle of it
right now things are going to a year
since the first
death let's just say it's been around a
year it's 12 months it's one year old
yeah shutting down is a year old we've
not experienced shut down before
so a question more of a follow-up yeah
but this isn't this
you know the truth is always somewhere
in the middle you know not
you know doing zoom non-stop and not
showing up in person
is obviously a ridiculous non-human uh
it just doesn't make sense but only
going to work
everyone doing that can be oftentimes
inefficient that's why i'm saying i'm
i'm in favor of this
flex option like you guys like you guys
put on big events you guys have meetings
php obviously valuetainment we're here
but you guys
also utilize a lot of zooms zoom has
helped your business immensely i never
discounted you know what i'm saying so
like
there is truth is somewhere in the
middle zoom to me is speed
zoom to me is not culture so remember
how everything to me is a ward like if
you want to talk about
people who like to control people why
are they controlling them controlling
trust right lazy is what
you know boredom you know you got the
bitterness is what
lack of creativity you're not creating
anything you're not part of a community
okay
when i think about zoom i think about
speed speed that's all i think about
i don't think about culture i don't
think about culture but they're
they're those are all important elements
to a business i don't disagree that
is important but culture is probably the
most important but that's
pretty damn important it is very
important but if there is no
uh okay so uh uh have you ever had along
to a long distance relationship
yes what do you say to a person who says
i love her but we see each other once a
quarter
what do you say to that quarter that's
ridiculous what do you say we see each
other once a month what do you tell them
bro like how do you what do you do the
rest but that's wait a minute what
happened to you all of a sudden you
flipped
zooming every day though uh-huh
no that's relationships come on now what
is culture
all right all right let's see where i
see where you're going oh a little bit
tipping point right there for you huh
the moment it got to are you gonna have
you ever had a long-distance
relationship
yeah but not not i would not see someone
once a month for
extended period of time then it's not a
long-distance relationship buddy what do
you do you see them once a week you fly
out to them and see them once a week no
it's not sustainable i think that's
where you're going yeah that's zoomed to
me
long distance relationship is zoom
yes okay what's your point
no i think i think pat has a good a lot
of good opinions and kind of input there
uh but i do think also that it's changed
the way where it's now more flexible
like get kind of going back to adam
with flexibility and also realizing that
the business
trip everyone thought everyone had to do
100 of the time
they realized now hey that like what if
we cut back half of those times
we move that money someplace elsewhere
where we can get more return for it
i think that has changed and probably
will stay that way for quite some time
even though things ease up and
restrictions and stuff like that because
they're kind of realizing
what is necessary but then also a lot of
the stuff that isn't necessary
i don't disagree i think the flex is
here i think uh uh
i think believe it or not i think kovit
hurt
commercial real estate yes but i think
covet also hurt
a lot of universities you know what do i
need to stay on campus now
okay what is the purpose of going to
college if you actually think about
what the hell is the purpose of going to
college yeah i have i have friends in
norway
in the us i want you to think about this
actually process it
what is the purpose of going to college
if you have kids right now what is the
number one reason you would want your
kids to go to a great college
well everyone has always said the
college experience which is what right
you know you're going to you're going to
parties and frat and going to class and
you're
all that but now if you're just zooming
what's the college experience but you
said that's a good idea though
saying there's there's a i'm in favor of
somewhere in the middle there's a flex
game so only 50 of students should go to
college
everybody else zooms in no i'm saying
you can go to classes on campus but also
you know
do i need to commute and i i'm just
saying a hypothetical commute an hour
to take a two-hour class to drive back
home an hour it's like dude let me just
zoom for this one freaking chloe just
got crushed
i'm in favor for that it's fine
eliminate 40 of them keep the 60
that can handle it what happens there
then again college is about experience
people relationships yes seeing what's
going on learning how to communicate
with people learning how to do soft
skills not just hard skills
i think i think you've been watching the
movie with uh joaquin phoenix heard too
much lately
and i think you got to stop watching
that movie her have you seen her paul
has anybody here seen her you've never
seen her have you seen her
you know what the st what's the story
about he's basically he builds a
relationship with his smartphone
so it's him and his smartphone and they
pretty much get into it he falls in love
with
her it's like you found hey siri how you
doing
hey baby wait
hey siri how you doing not too shabby
thanks for asking that's my series why'd
y'all serious sound like he's a joke
that's nice
he's an engineer he's a joke that's my
that's my uh siri right
okay hello patrick big david good to see
you again
i i think the direction we're going is
adam's gonna have a uh uh
uh virtual reality all you hard hot ass
smartphones out there holler at your boy
i'm here
it's going to be the situation i'm
dating somebody who can we see her not
yet can we see her not yet not yet not
yet i'm trying not to she's from germany
though
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye